Welcome to the drama show today. We have these special guests.
We have my ex-girlfriend joining us today.
So why don't you introduce yourself?
Why always me? Yeah. So in case you didn't understand a joke,
what I was saying is that I don't have an ex-girlfriend because I'd never had a
girlfriend, which is kind of true. I mean,
I wouldn't consider the ones I had in middle school and high school,
real relationships, because it wasn't really driven by love or anything.
It was primarily driven by horniness and nothing else. And then in college,
it was really hard for me to be in a relationship.
And the reason why was because I went to university of Waterloo.
Now it's not because darn any girls there it's because we move every four
months.
So four months I would be in school in that four month that would be working.
So if you meet a girl and you hit it off, you know, it's real nice.
And then three months later,
you have to move out and it's not worth being in a long distance relationship
when you only met each other for like four months.
So I think that's the primary reason why I was never in the relationships.
And also because I'm a slide away, new videos, every Thursday,
I finally chose a schedule. I am going to post on Thursdays from now on,
at 12:00 PM Eastern time. I even made a cover photo for it. So it's pretty dope.
It's pretty official. And, uh, yeah.
And also another thing don't forget to follow me on Instagram at Jamal pod,
because from now on, I'm going to live stream on Instagram.
And the reason why I chose Instagram is because YouTube is getting too big for
me. And I can't have like a proper conversation with you guys.
So I chose Instagram to make it smaller so that at least I can have more of a
conversation or I can answer all the questions. All right.
So today I am going to bring you guys to the office,
which is actually pretty cool because I finally got the approval to film at the
office. The only thing is that I have to blur everything out.
That's too sensitive or that HR said I can't film, but yeah, I'm pretty excited.
All right, let's go. This is the gym, this,
and this is my desk and this is sun me.
The. I'm not some me, bro. I'm not even.
Korean. And then now we are at the roof, as you can see, it's a beautiful view.
All right. I hope you enjoyed that tour. And now it's time to go back home.
So now I'm going to Cameron's I'm going to say hello to him.
Cause it's been a while. I haven't seen him. Your camera was popping and we go,
what the are you doing, dude? What, what, what is this? It's nothing.
Oh, wait.
[inaudible] you were saying you were coming at 10 30.
I just want to surprise you. I mean, come on man. dude. Why are you filming?
Still do yo my God. Your hand, right?
It's a little sticky.
Oh, dude. This is actually pretty cool. God, it's so realistic.
Holy.
All right. Let's just do a little bit of coding. All right.
So let me just show you a dope ID. It's called Microsoft word.
I don't know if you ever heard of that, but it's pretty cool.
Cause like Chickasaw, just like syntax highlighting, you know,
you could just change the color, like this change, the color like that.
So though, I mean,
I don't think any IDE can customize your colors that much.
So yeah, it's pretty much, this is like the dopest idea I've ever used. So.
Simple yet
delicate in flavor and texture.
They have the power of persuasion stronger than that.
Emotions
says that no man has ever resisted the temptation of
perfect balance of crisp cookies and rich,
impossible to find.
All right. So I just wanted to tell you guys, um,
I went to VidCon a few days ago and I actually had a lot of clips. So funny.
You know, I filmed a lot of people, a lot of my coworkers, but I lost it all.
I'm very, very sad. The only thing I have left.
So we hung out for the whole weekend. Like
we hung out for the whole weekend.
Sort of you feel like our bond is stronger now because we
hung out. I feel like it's much worse.
I learned that you flirt by trying to quiz people about data science,
say something nice about me so that so that my audience can feel hashtag
relatable to me. You know what I mean? What is nice about, okay.
I'll just tell you what to say and you say it. Sure. Okay. You have to say,
you know Jonathan. No. No. Okay. Sorry.
I've never called you because whenever people call me Jonathan,
he like Morrisons are warm, but probably people call you Jonathan. Not a lot.
Probably Jonathan sometimes like in bed.
Wait, does anyone in here? Like when you're, well,
let me think, because that's like kind of funny, actually they did.
They never say my name in bed because it's not like they get excited or
anything. They me to say other people's names, but yeah.
Say something like Joma,
you could seem very silly at times and sometimes even kind of mean,
but in reality he's actually a very sweet person and it would,
and that has shown multiple times today. Can you say that,
you know,
sometimes Gemma seems kind of dumb kinda mean, but uh,
it turns out that's entirely true. I didn't say Dom first of all.
Oh my God. All right. I'm done for today. Thanks for watching the blog.
Peace out.
I didn't shave cause this time I'm not sponsored by dollar shave club.
[Inaudible]
that's what I look like when I'm having sex.